Sehr gut.
Guten Abend. Mein Name ist Shadi Aldis. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeschef führen.
Bevor wir Ihre aktuelle Beschwerde kommen, soll ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich. Klar, Sie müssen wissen.
Fast irgendetwas, was unklar ist, fragen Sie gerne nach.
Was heißt Sie denn?
Ich heiße Paul Lindemann.
Paul Lindermann.
Lindemann.
Lindemann, Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Nachname bestabieren?
Ja, L-I-N-D-E.
Und dann M-A-N-N.
M-A-N-N, double N.
Ja.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Herr Lindemann.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 69 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 23., 3., 56.
56, ja.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,79.
Wie viel wiegen Sie aktuelle Wissen Sie?
Ja, ich wiege nur noch 74 kg.
74 kg.
Ich habe abgenommen in der ganzen Zeit.
Vielen Dank.
Was führt Sie zu uns?
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, ich habe schon seit geraumer Zeit immer mal Bauchschmerzen.
Und bin mit mir so selber gar nicht zufrieden,
dass ich so schlapp bin.
Und dass es mir nicht schmeckt.
Ja, auch mit der Verdauung habe ich Probleme.
Und heute Morgen ist mir etwas aufgefallen.
Und das hat mich jetzt schon so ein bisschen erschreckt.
Ich war auf der Toilette und das sah ganz schwarz aus.
Also ganz dunkel.
Und ja, das hat mich da schon ein bisschen erschreckt.
Und deswegen habe ich dann gedacht, ich komme doch eben schnell
hier zu Ihnen mein Haus, als es gerade im Urlaub.
Und deswegen bin ich gleich zu Ihnen gekommen.
Ja, Sie haben sehr gut gemacht hier zu kommen.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt? Seit wann?
Also das ist eigentlich schon seit Wochen,
dass ich mich schlecht fühle.
Ja, und auch so in den letzten Monaten,
dass ich eben so wahnsinnig abgenommen habe.
Das hat mich eigentlich gewundert.
Und ja, und jetzt, also dass das alles zusammengekommen ist.
Und jetzt eben diese Sache, dass das so schwarz aussah.
Ja, da habe ich dann schon ein bisschen schreckt bekommen.
Ja Mensch, jetzt muss ich aber doch mal los.
Ja, es tut mir sehr leid.
Das ist sehr unangenehm.
Sie haben diese Beschwerden als starke eine Woche.
Waren Sie beim anderen Arzt in dieser Zeit?
Nein, ich wollte immer noch mal zum Arzt,
sondern war ja Sommerzeit und Urlaubzeit.
Und jetzt ist er auch im Urlaub.
Und deswegen bin ich direkt hierher gekommen.
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Herr Lindermann, Sie haben gesagt, Bauchschmerzen.
Wo ist die Schmerzen genau lokalisiert?
Ja, so hier im oberen Bauchanteil,
also so oberhalb vom Bauchnabel würde ich sagen.
Und was ich auch gemerkt habe,
also nachts kann ich im Bett schaft nicht liegen.
Ich habe solche Rückenschmerzen.
Ich habe schon gedacht, ob irgendwas mit dem Rücken ist,
weil das so weh tut, wenn ich im Bett liege.
Rückenschmerzen haben Sie gesprungen?
Ja, so wie Gürtel.
Bitte?
So wie Gürtel, Ihre Schmerzenschütteralen.
Nein, nein, nein.
Nur wenn ich lange liege,
habe ich das Gefühl, dass es im Rücken wehtut.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind Sie dumpf oder stehende oder ziehende?
Ja, sehr gut.
Sie drücken so dumpfer Druck, würde ich sagen.
Und die Schmerzen sind gar nicht so schlimm.
Aber sie sind halt so permanent da.
Und am Anfang war das natürlich so,
dass man es kaum wahrgenommen hat,
aber es ist irgendwie jetzt doch ein bisschen mehr geworden.
Und weil ich mich auch so schlapp fühle und so.
Ja, verstehe ich.
Sie haben gesagt, wenn Sie auf den Rücken liegen,
haben Sie Rücken Schmerzen.
Schmerzen, ihr geht heute Körperteile aus,
in Rücken oder andere Körperteile?
Nein, nein, das ist eigentlich normal.
Überwiegend sind die Bauchschmerzen,
aber wie gesagt, im Liegen tut es mir dann auch im Rücken weh.
Rücken weh, andere Schmerzen.
Richtig.
Sie haben Schmerzen ohne Schmertralen.
Ich würde mich nicht aus die Schmerzen rücken.
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt,
dass die Schmerzen lindert oder verstack?
Eigentlich kann ich das nicht sagen.
Ich esse schon ganz vorsichtig,
weil ich immer das Gefühl habe vom Bauch her,
dass es mir besser bekommt, wenn ich kleine Mahlzeiten esse.
Und es schmeckt mir eben auch eigentlich gar nicht.
Selbst wenn meine Frau mir etwas Gutes kocht,
dann bin ich eigentlich so mitgerichend mit dem Essen.
Das ist eigentlich ganz würdig.
Fleisch schmeckt mir zum Beispiel überhaupt gar nicht.
Ich habe früher immer so gerne auch meinen guten Braten
oder etwas gegessen.
Aber nie, das will ich jetzt gar nicht.
Ich denke immer, das macht es so erträglich,
wenn ich vorsichtig esse.
Zur Zeit trinke ich auch nicht so viel.
Sonst habe ich immer gerne mein Bier getrunken
oder auch mal ein Schnäppchen oder so.
Selbst das schmeckt mir jetzt im Augenblick eigentlich gar nicht.
Herr Lindermann,
wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10?
1 bedeutet leite Schmerzen,
10 bedeutet unverdägliche Schmerzen.
Wie schätzen Sie da?
Das ist so, ich würde sagen, in der Mitte.
Es ist nicht so, dass ich das nicht aushalten könnte.
Aber ich laufe da ja auch schon eine Weile mit rum.
Aber es ist eben so ein permanenter Druck.
Ja, permanent und drücken.
Aber ich würde sagen, sie in der Mitte bei 4 bis 5.
5.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Sie haben über Abgenommen gescheppelt.
Im letzten Zeit haben Sie zu oder abgenommen bemerkt?
Ja, habe ich doch gesagt, ich habe deutlich abgenommen.
Ich habe 10 kg runter.
10 kg?
Ja, am letzten halben Jahr.
Letzte Jahr.
Halbe Jahr.
Ja, Herr Lindermann, Sie haben über Schwartse dunkel Stül gesprochen.
Könnten Sie bitte ein bisschen erklären,
seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Das war erst heute Morgen.
Jede Stül ist Schwartse oder nichts.
Erst heute Morgen, habe ich doch gesagt.
Erst heute Morgen, okay.
Haben Sie außer der Übelkeit oder Erbrechen Probleme?
Ja, natürlich ist mir schlecht.
Ich habe mich auch jetzt in letzter Zeit 2-mal übergeben in der letzten Woche.
Wie sieht Ihre Erbrochen aus?
Ja, das sah komisch aus.
Das sah ziemlich dunkel aus eigentlich.
Anders als das, was ich eigentlich gegessen hatte.
Ich habe mich noch gefunden.
Ja, Herr Lindermann, haben Sie Schluckprobleme gemerkt?
Ist bei Ihnen eine Schluckbeschwerden aufgefallen?
Schluckbeschwerden in dem Sinne nicht.
Manchmal muss ich so ein bisschen sauer aufstüßen.
Aber eigentlich so richtige Schluckbeschwerden habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Herzrasen, Herzstorben oder Gusten oder
ist noch ab eine Probleme gemerkt?
Nein, vom Herzen glaube ich, das Herz habe ich, habe ich keine Probleme, würde ich sagen.
Das ist sehr gut.
Ja, Atemprobleme.
Ich bin schlapp, aber fühle mich nicht so leistungsfähig.
Ich puste schon, wenn ich eine Treppe hochlaufe und mich ein bisschen anstrengen.
Aber sehr gut, ich bin ja auch nicht mehr der Jüngste.
Herr Lindermann, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Lieben Sie Ihre Frau?
Und was?
Lieben Sie zusammen in Ihrem Familie?
Sind meine Frauen wohl nicht zusammen?
Ja, die Kinder sind aus dem Haus.
Sie haben etwas bemerkt, dass Sie Blase aussiehen, im letzter Zeit.
Ja, das hat sie schon gesagt.
Sie hat immer schön gekocht für mich, meine Frau.
Du ist hier gar nichts und du siehst ganz schlecht aus.
Du musst mal wieder ein bisschen essen.
Sie hat auch immer gedacht, ich soll mal zum Arzt gehen.
Männer gehen ja nicht so gerne zum Arzt.
Ja, haben Sie Ihre Appetit nicht gut im letzter Zeit?
Sie haben gesagt, wie liefen Sie im letzter Zeit?
Schlafen Sie gut?
Meistens muss ich zwei bis drei Mal in der Nacht,
zwei Mal höchstens in der Nacht, auf die Toilette.
Dann habe ich auch ein bisschen Probleme wieder einzuschlafen.
Aber ich bin jetzt errennt, ich kann morgen ein bisschen länger schlafen.
Haben Sie noch andere, was Sie lassen, Probleme?
Sie haben in der Nacht zwei Mal auf die Toilette, Sie müssen auf die Toilette gehen.
Noch andere Beschwerde haben Sie etwas bemerkt, bei dem, was Sie lassen?
Sonst alles nicht.
Gut, das ist sehr gut.
Ich möchte ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer kranken Vorgeschichte stellen.
Leiden Sie an chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe seit 15 Jahren ein Alterszucker mit Formientabletten nehmen.
Damit geht es mir aber eigentlich ganz gut.
Ein 1000 mg, 400 mg mit Formi.
Woher nehme ich denn da, es gibt es 800 oder 800?
Ich glaube, 800, das nehme ich morgens ein.
Einmal morgen, ja.
Und ja, ich habe ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck, aber da nehme ich eigentlich im Augenblick noch keine Medikamente.
Das hat der Arzt nur mal gesagt, dass ich da eigentlich ein bisschen aufpassen müsste.
Haben Sie noch andere chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob das eine Rolle spielt.
Beide Knie und beide Hüften sind eingeschränkt, da habe ich überall Arthrose in den großen Gelenken.
Deswegen bin ich auch nicht mehr so selbst beweglich.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Schmerzmittel?
Ja, wenn ich starke Schmerzen habe, dann nehme ich Ibuprofen, dass ich so den Tag über die Runden komme.
Gerade wenn ich mal etwas vor habe oder wenn wir eine Reise machen mal irgendwo hin,
dann habe ich schon mal eine Schmerzmittel dabei, damit ich da über die Tage komme.
Wie viel Milligramm Ibuprofen nehmen Sie, erinnern Sie Sie daran?
Bitte.
Wie viel Milligramm Ibuprofen, wie dosis?
Ich glaube, das sind immer so 600er Tabletten.
Nehmen Sie Magenschutzmedikamente?
Nein.
Gehen Sie dabei bei Bedarf?
Okay, wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, als Kind natürlich, da habe ich die Mande rausbekommen.
Und, was habe ich denn noch gehabt?
Ja, nur die Mande, eigentlich alles andere.
Alles andere ist noch da, sonst habe ich keine Operation.
Gut, das ist sehr gut.
Ich habe vergessen, seit wann haben Sie diese Artloseprobleme
und seit wann haben Sie diese Medikamente eingenommen?
Ja, die Artlose, das hat sich schon so bemerkbar gemacht,
als ich immer in die Rente gegangen bin.
Ja, eigentlich auch schon ein bisschen verletzt,
seit zehn Jahren, kann man sagen.
Okay.
Sie haben über Medformen und Ibuprofen gesprochen.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf noch andere Medikamente ein?
Zum Beispiel pflanzliche Medikamente zu Schlafengilfe oder andere Probleme?
Ne, sonst nehme ich eigentlich nix.
Das ist sehr gut.
Sonst trinke ich abends mal ein Bier, dann kann man auch geschlafen.
Okay, das ist sehr gut.
Sind bei Ihnen Allergien bekannt oder Unverträglichkeit bekannt?
Ja, tatsächlich darf ich kein Noval hinnehmen.
Das hatte ich irgendwann mal gezeigt,
dass ich da heftigen Hauenausschlags bekomme.
Bis zu Luftnot.
Und was ich auch nicht vertrage, ist Jod.
Ich darf also auch keine jod-haltigen Sachen nehmen.
Wie reagiert es Jod?
Auch mit Luftnot.
Das hat mal so ein Beinart Zwischenfall gegeben.
Ja, das verstehe ich.
Noch andere Unverträglichkeit haben Sie?
Ne, sonst eigentlich.
Gut, ja.
Rauchen Sie, Herr Lindermann?
Ja, also ich rauche jetzt nur noch seit 10 Jahren,
ich rauche nur noch ganz wenig.
Ich rauche nur noch 10 Zigaretten am Tag.
Zurzeit schmecken Sie mir aber auch eigentlich nicht, muss ich sagen.
Aber früher habe ich schon viele, viele Jahre
ein Päckchen am Tag geraucht.
Ich bin schon sehr froh, dass ich dazu eingeschränkt habe.
Ungefähr 20 bis 30 Jahre?
Bestimmt 30 Jahre, ja, ja.
Sie haben sehr gute Entscheidungen getroffen,
um mit Rauchen zu reduzieren.
Ja, ja, das ist so schwer, wissen Sie?
Sie haben über Bier-Trumpen gesprochen.
Sie haben gut geschlafen.
Ja, ich kriege meistens jeden Abend 2 Flaschen Bier.
Manchmal auch einen Schnaps, aber wie gesagt, er schnappt zur Zeit.
Ja, da merke ich, dass wenn ich so gut bekomme,
da habe ich ihn jetzt auch meistens weggenassen.
Okay.
Könnten Sie mir bitte sagen, Herr Lindermann,
dass Ihre Eltern,
ist Ihre Eltern chronische Erkrankungen entschuldige?
Leiden Ihre Eltern chronische Erkrankungen?
Meine Eltern sind beide schon verstorben, die sind alle nicht alt geworden.
Und mein Vater, der hatte Darmkrebs.
Und der ist kurz nach der Rente, so mit Ende 60,
68 oder 69 ist er verstorben.
Und meine Mutter war schwer depressiv.
Und ja, die ist dann mit dem Verlust nicht klar gekommen.
Als sie alleine war, die hat sich dann tatsächlich das Leben genommen.
Ja, haben Sie Geschwester?
Nein, ich war Einzelkind.
Sie sind Rentnerin?
Entschuldige, Sie sind Rentner?
Ja, ja.
Was haben Sie früher?
Oh, ich habe viele Jahre in der Autowerkstatt gearbeitet, als Mechaniker.
Auto?
Als Kfz-Mechaniker.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, aber die sind schon groß, unsere Kinder, die sind schon aus dem Haus.
Ja, gut. Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, so viel ich weiß, ja.
Gut.
Ich möchte noch andere Fragen zu Ihrer aktuelle Beschwerden stellen.
Haben Sie im letzten Zeit Ihre Haut gelb verfarbend bemerkt?
Nein, gelb nicht.
Also meine Frau hat gesagt, ich sehe ein bisschen Blass aus.
Blass, ja?
Ja, Blass, aber gelb hat sie jetzt nicht gesagt und ist mir auch nicht ausgefallen.
Das ist sehr gut, ja.
Ich habe alle wichtige Fragen für mich gestellt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, ich habe Ihnen das sehr viel erzählt.
Ich möchte jetzt nur wissen, woher das kommt.
Ich habe natürlich auch ein bisschen Angst,
wissen Sie wegen der Geschichte von meinem Vater mit seinem Darmentrebs?
Ja, Sie haben es recht.
Insofern bin ich natürlich jetzt schon so ein bisschen besorgt.
Und ja, auch, was man wieder machen kann, damit es mir wieder besser geht.
Ich möchte noch ein bisschen Pip in die Birgit,
ich will ja noch ein bisschen meine Rente genießen.
Ja, wir können nicht 100% Krebserkrankungen ausschließen.
Aber es ist viele Möglichkeiten, um diese Beschwerden zu verursachen.
Bitte denken Sie nicht am schließendsten Situation.
Wir können zusammen ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen
und wir können finden, was Sie haben.
Ja, okay.
Was für Untersuchungen machen wir denn?
Ja, zuerst machen wir eine körperliche Untersuchung.
Dann werde ich Blut abnehmen und Laboruntersuchungen durchführen
und ein paar bildgebende Verfahren durchführen,
zum Beispiel Ultraschall oder Bauch Ultraschall oder Bauch CT.
Computerisatomografie.
Wissen Sie Computerisatomografie?
Nee, was ist das?
Wiederholende Röntgen.
Sie liegen auf einem Tisch und wird die Tisch in eine ringförmige Maschine geschoben.
Verschoben und die Maschine nimmt verschiedene Bilder aus
und die Computer erzeugt als Schnittbilder ihre innere Organen.
Wie können die diagnostizierten, was sie haben?
Aber hat das nicht eine ganz hohe Strahlendelastung?
Ja, ein bisschen strahlend Belastung, aber die strahlend Belastung
ist sehr, sehr gering und nicht schädlich für Gesundheit.
Und wehtun tut das auch nicht?
Nein, nicht Schmerz.
Das ist eine schmerzfreie Risikofrei und sehr, sehr moderne Untersuchung.
Es dauert ungefähr fünf bis zehn Minuten.
Das klingt ja gut, ja.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Möchte noch jemand eine Frage stellen?
Alle sind völlig zufrieden.
Sie sagen Bescheid, wenn Sie soweit sind, dass Sie Arztgespräche machen wollen.
Okay.
Ich möchte einen neuen Patient vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, natürlich.
Herr Paul Lindermann ist ein 69-jähriger Patient,
der sich seitlich örtlich und persönlich vollständig orientiert
in normal gewichtigem Ernährungszustand
und beschwerdebedingte, deutlich reduziertem Allgemeinzustand.
Der Patient stellte sich heute bei uns seit ungefähr fünf Tagen
bestehende Persistierende eine Woche, bestehende Persistierende,
bestehende Persistierende, druckende, dumfe Abdominalgie
und fatig vor, die von Melana begleitet sei.
Und die Schmerzen seien im Oberbau insbesondere
unter Epidemastrik, oberperiomplikal bereit.
Und die Intensität der Schmerzen wurde mit fünf von zehn
auf numerische Skala angegeben.
Sie haben nicht, Sie entschuldigen,
er habe nicht besondere Auslöser bemerkt.
Darüber hinaus klagte er über Gewicht verlost,
innerhalb sechs Monaten, innerhalb von sechs Monaten,
von zehn Kilogramm.
Oh ja.
Ja, starker.
Ja.
Außerdem leide er unter Übelkeit und zweimal
vomitis, das erbrochene Sicht,
das erbrochene Sicht dunkel aus.
Das ist auch.
Ja.
Laut seiner Freundin, siehe er Blase aus.
Sieht er Blase aus.
Ja.
Darüber hinaus klagte er über Rückenschmerzen,
insbesondere wenn er auf Rücken liegen,
beim Rücken, beim Rücken, beim Liegen, ja.
Beim Liegen in Rückenlaube.
Ja, kundigung.
Darüber hinaus berichtete er,
letzte Zeit, berichtete er im letzten Zeit Sauerstoff,
Entschuldige, unter Sauerstoff zu leiden.
Unter Sauerstoff zu leiden?
Sauerstoff, Entschuldige, Sauerstoff.
Sauerstoff, ja, unter Sauerstoff, hin und wieder.
Sauerstoff, um zu leiden, richtig, entschuldigen.
Und die Vegetationamnese ist auch oben genannte Symptome
und Nekturi und einschlafen Probleme unauffällig.
Ja, also es ist nicht unauffällig,
es ist schon ja ein bisschen auffällig, ne?
Ja.
Auf die Frage nach Dispne und Herzprobleme
wurden verneid.
Ja, und für Erkrankungen leiden er seit 15 Jahre Diabetes mellitus.
Die Medikamentös mit Metformin, 800 mg,
einmal täglich behandelt worden sein.
Darüber hinaus leiden er, leiden er Arterealehypertonie,
aber dagegen neime er keine Medikamente mit
konservativ behandelt worden sein.
Okay, ne?
Ja, außerdem leiden er ungefähr seit 10 Jahre Artrose,
insbesondere gross gelen Artrose,
die Medikamentös iboprofen Baibedarf, 600 mg,
behandelt worden sein.
Ah, so eine reine Schmerzmedikation.
Erneime keine Magenschutzmedikamente ein.
Ah ja.
Und bei ihm sei als Kind wegen Mandeln vergrößert,
eine Operation durchgeführt worden.
Umfach begrofen?
Ja, alles hat gut gemacht.
Im Bezug auf Medikation nehmen er schon genannte Medikamente.
Keine andere Medikamente.
Auf die Frage nach Allergien und Unverträglichkeiten,
gab der Patient an auf Novalgin,
um auf Novalgin zu dispen und auch auf Schmack entzündigen.
Exantem zu reagieren, darüber hinaus habe er J-Allergie,
die sich als Dispner zu äußeren.
Mit Dispner?
Ja, mit Dispner, entschuldige, mit Dispner äußeren.
An Noxem Verhalten berichtete er,
seit mehrere Jahren ungefähr 14 Jahre raucher zu sein.
Erraucher, letzte 10 Jahre,
mit einer No-A-Zigarette täglich,
aber davor habe er ungefähr 30 Jahre einpacken.
Er trink jede Abend ein bis zwei Flasche Biya.
Ich vergesse Drogenkonsum,
während die Körperlische untersuchen,
frage ich dir.
An Familienanamnese ergab eine Kolonkarcinombi,
der Vater des Patienten ist mit 69 Jahren daran verstorben.
Ah, und der Patient ist gerade genauso ein.
Die Mutadespazientin leide an Depressionen,
sehr starker Depressionen.
Die Erzei Einzelkind, Erzei Verheiratet und Habe Kinder,
aber sie sind gesund, Erzei rennt her,
davor habe er als Automekaniker Arbeit.
Die Arbeit ist schon.
Die Anamnestischenangaben deuten am ehesten auf eine Magenkrebs hin.
Magenkarcinom hin.
Dafür spricht von allem Melena, Bauchschmerzen,
Fatigue, Blassaussehen und unterstütze,
meine Verdachtdiagnose, die Risikofaftörern
sowie Familienerkrankungen,
Darmkarcinom und ja,
Was wäre den Differenzialdiagnose?
Nikotinkonsum auch.
Was wäre den Differenzialdiagnose noch möglich?
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommen die folgenden Erkrankungen
in Betracht, Ulcus ventriculi
und pancreas carcinoma.
Vielleicht Galinblase oder Galinblase carcinoma.
Oder Zephagus carcinoma.
Ja, jedenfalls nichts Gutes.
Was machen Sie denn diagnostisch mit den Patienten?
Zuerst sollen wir körperliche Untersuchungen durchführen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen?
Die Schmerzen und Schmerzcharakter
und Lokalisieren sollen wir achten auf Schmerzlokalisial.
Sie sieht Blasse aus.
Wie sollen dann Ihre Scyklere überprüfen?
Ja, das ist wichtig.
Wo noch gucken Sie noch?
Bei der orientierenden körperlichen Untersuchungen?
Ja, wie sollen Bauch abtasten
und insbesondere Magenbereich sehr gut abtasten
und gibt es große oder harte Gewäbe?
Ja, ob man da schon etwas abtasten kann.
Was würden Sie noch abtasten?
Ja, viele Organvergrößerung sollen wir abtasten
und auch sollen wir Druckschmerzen,
Abwehrspannung oder Loslassschmerzen überprüfen.
Wie ist es mit Luftknotenstationen?
Es ist möglich, aber bei der körperlichen Untersuchung
können wir nicht sehr guter Luftknoten finden.
Vielleicht leistend Bereich können wir finden.
Ich überprüfe ein leistend Bereich
wegen Luftknotenvergrößerung.
Was machen Sie weiter?
Wir sollen laboruntersuchung durchführen.
Ich werde Blut abnehmen und laboruntersuchung durchführen.
Insbesondere sollen wir Blutbild, Entzündung, Parameter
und Anämie.
Dann sollen wir CA-19 überprüfen.
Wir überprüfen ja Leber- und Nierenwerte
und Elektronikwerte.
Routinemäßig sollen wir eine EKG durchführen.
Was machen Sie noch?
Der Patient weidet an Diabetes mellitus.
Deswegen sollen wir Blutzuckerwerte
und gelikisierte Hemoglobin überprüfen.
Was haben wir noch für einen Labor-Tank?
Stuhlprobe und Urinstatus.
Wie geht es mit der operativen Medizin weiter?
Das ist sehr wichtig.
Die operative Verfahren spielen eine sehr wichtige Rolle.
Die Diagnose dieser Erkrankungen
sollen wir zuerst abdominal-utrisch durchführen.
Und außerdem sollen wir eine Gastroendoskopie.
Ein schreckliches Wort.
Gleichzeitig können wir eine Gewerbe-Probe entnehmen.
Und mit der Mikroskop-Labor sollen wir diese Gewerbe analysieren.
Wir haben den Patienten schon etwas angekündigt,
was sie noch für eine Untersuchung machen wollen.
Wir sollen die CT-Untersuchung durchführen,
um eine Metastase zu erklären.
Vielleicht gibt es verschiedene Organmetastasen.
Wir wollen die Behandlung der Möglichkeiten und Entscheidungen erkennen.
Dann sieht es nicht gut aus für den Patienten.
Halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden,
dass bei Ihren Untersuchungen rauskommt.
Der bleibt bei uns.
Wir wollen die Behandlung der Erkrankungen nach Schwerigrad.
Vielleicht das erste oder zweite Stadium.
Das ist sehr gut für die Behandlung.
Vielleicht ist die Behandlung nicht gut.
Die Behandlung richtet von konservativen Therapien
über medikamentöse Therapien bis hin zu operativen Handlungen.
Genau, so machen wir es.
Wir wollen die Diagnostik.
Wir sollen das Konzult anmelden.
Auf alle Fälle sollten wir das tun.
Danke.
Wir haben eine sehr schöne Anamese gemacht.
Sie haben auch einen guten Arztgespräch geführt.
Sie haben immer noch ein bisschen Erdbeutung.
Sie haben immer noch ein bisschen wenig Satzmelodie.
Sie sprechen ganz exakt.
Das kann man Ihnen gar nicht zum Vorwurf machen.
Es klingt ein bisschen mechanisch.
Ich habe es mir ausgedeilt.
Ich überlege immer, was es im Vergleich zu jemandem der Muttersprachlich
Deutsch spricht.
Es ist so, dass Sie die Sätze zum Satzende gehen Sie nicht runter
mit der Stimme.
Sie betonen jede Silbe ganz exakt.
Sie sprechen sehr exakt.
Man hört jede Silbe.
Man hört auch, dass sie ...
Wie soll ich sagen?
Es klingt ein bisschen mechanisch.
Nicht organisch.
Aber ich glaube, dass Sie das nicht so gut machen.
Man kann Sie aber wirklich ausgezeichnet verstehen.
Das ist kein Ding.
Sie haben auch keine Probleme mit den Patienten zu sprechen.
Das hat mir immer gut gefallen.
Sie haben schon erwähnt, dass Sie rauchen zum Bereich.
Sie trinken Bier.
Sie haben auch schon erwähnt, dass Sie rauchen zum Bereich.
Sie haben das Gefühl, ich habe zugehört.
Eigentlich habe ich nur drei kleine Sachen mir notiert.
Ein Mann mit 1,79 Größe, 74 kg.
Das ist untergewichtig.
Ein Meter, neun.
Ein Meter, neun, 74 kg.
Das ist normal.
Der gute Junge ist verheiratet.
Sie haben gesagt, die Freundin hat gesagt, er ist Blass.
Die Frau freut sich, dass er immer noch die Freundin ist.
Aber er ist die Ehefrau.
Dann, was Sie nicht richtig gehört haben,
er hat gesagt, der Vater ist früh gestorben an dem Krebs.
Die Mutter hat schwere Depressionen
und hat sich danach das Leben genommen,
als der Vater verstorben ist.
Das haben Sie nicht gesagt.
Das ist eine Frage,
die Sie nicht erwähnen.
Normalerweise sage ich immer,
wenn die Eltern tot sind,
weil jemand, der 70 Jahre alt ist,
das ist normal.
Da braucht man nichts zu kontrollieren.
Beim Suizid würde ich vielleicht ein Wort darüber verlieren.
Das tut mir leid.
Das war bestimmt schwer für Sie.
Das ist immer noch so eine Sache,
die mit den Hinterbliebenen sehr viel Macht
und sehr belastend ist.
Erwähnen würde ich das schon im Arztgespräch.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Sie ihn durchgerutscht haben,
dass Sie es nicht gehört haben,
dass Sie es nicht gehört haben.
Das war das Einzige.
Bei den ganzen medizinischen Sachen
sind Sie nichts schuldig geblieben.
Das ist gut gelaufen.
Wann ist die Prüfung?
Ich habe keine Termine,
aber ich möchte Ihnen eine erklären.
Sie haben mir nach meiner
ersten Simulation gesagt,
mein Sprach ist ein bisschen Mechanik.
Ich denke darauf,
ich lerne Deutsch mit immer
Google Translate.
Ich höre immer Google Translate.
Jetzt habe ich einen Sprachpartnerin gefunden
und ich versuche,
meine Sprach zu verbessern
und ein bisschen Melodisch.
Wenn Sie darauf achten,
ich kann nur sagen,
gucken Sie ein bisschen deutsches Fernsehen,
wie reden die Leute tatsächlich im Alltag?
Es ist schon hilfreich, glaube ich.
Nachrichtensprecher sprechen natürlich immer richtig und exakt,
aber auch die sprechen nicht so mechanisch.
Wir haben auch ein bisschen Melodisch,
aber es ist immer noch so spürbar.
Mir fällt es immer auf.
Ich denke immer, das, was ich merke,
kann ich sagen.
Ich kann Ihnen da Tipps geben,
dass es noch besser wird.
Sehr schöne Anamnese,
wirklich sehr schönes als Arztgespräch.
Vielen Dank.
Meine Sprachpartnerin hat gesagt,
ich besser bin als ich besser bin.
Aber ich werde du können.